we know of course you're going to be
speaking to the conservatives at
conference Boris Johnson was always a
key Ally of President zielinski are you
seeing the same from Liz truss
we are we are seeing the same from his
trust also from her government we were
extremely happy that the Minister of
Defense didn't change so we have a
continuity there of uh of support for
the Ukrainian military for of
collaboration with the Ukrainian
minister of defense
and uh of course all this means that the
UK and Ukraine continue to to work uh on
their strong strategic partnership
I want to talk a little bit about the
situation on the grounds in Ukraine we
all know of course about the
extraordinary bravery of the ukrainians
in a war that many people expected would
be over in a matter of weeks you're
continuing to retake territory what is
the situation on the ground and how
optimistic or not are you
I'm fairly optimistic and despite Putin
trying to distract from from the
advances of the Ukrainian Army in the
east of Ukraine uh the Ukrainian Army is
still advancing regardless of the
annexation announcements regardless of
the Sham referendum all of that is
absolutely meaningless when it comes to
the Ukrainian military units coming
forward and liberating the Ukrainian
people and reinstalling the Ukrainian
flag in uh well pretty much all all
across the the east of Ukraine so we
have the luhan's region the netsk region
we have advancements being made in the
parisia and her son today and over the
coming days as well so it's looking
pretty good on the front lines for
Ukraine but of course we are still
reliant on the support that we are
getting from our allies including the UK
in terms of weapons and in terms of
ammunition we need those to be coming in
larger numbers and in faster time for
Ukraine to secure a quick Victory
because a quick victory is exactly what
the whole world needs today we cannot be
fighting this war for another year or
years to come this will deplete Ukraine
this will deplete the sources of the
allies and this will strengthen the
Tyranny and the Empire that Putin is
trying to build so desperately
at the same time of course Putin has
held these Sham referenda in four
regions of Ukraine where a surprise
surprise people voted to join Russia how
is Ukraine responding to that
the thing is people didn't vote
so uh that's the whole point of a sham
referenda where you have the results
fixed and where you have a bare minimum
of respondents so some two maybe three
percent of uh the population of all
these regions were participating in the
referenda and a lot of the answers were
obtained by actually holding people at
gunpoint or by inflicting threats on on
people and their families uh and even at
that some some were still responding in
the negative that they didn't want to
join Russia and again I I go back to to
the survey results to sorry two percent
of the population of those regions voted
that that's hardly the will of the
people you know this is how Ukraine
looks on these referenda they're just
nothing they're they're just you know a
fiction of Putin's imagination who would
like to see his Empire and stated but uh
we as you know normal sane people who
want to live in the Free World who are
fighting for democracy and freedom we we
cannot um take seriously the fantasies
of a psychopathic Tyrant leader
do we need to take them seriously though
because he is also hinted at the use of
nuclear weapons he said that the regions
are now part of Russia so he's Justified
to protect them by all available means
and he also says there's a precedent
created by the United States to use
nuclear weapons how worried are you
about that
well Sophie and all honesty he has been
threatening nuclear uh threats from from
February onwards none of them
materialized the fact that he now has a
legal ground in his mind to treat these
territories as if they were Russia
changes nothing because on the onset on
the 24th of February the Russians
invaded Ukraine saying that they are
liberating Ukraine from something
essentially implying that they were
already treating these territories as if
they were Russia and Putin was clear
that he would be prepared to go to to to
all means in March he mobilized or he
said that he was mobilizing the nuclear
Arsenal to be ready for deployment at
any point it still wasn't used I used I
think that um Russia and the Russian
line of command realized first the uh
the consequences of the use of such
weapons first and foremost for the
people in Russia because it's a nuclear
weapon it's not going to to be contained
within a secretary tree the aftermath is
going to spread the results are going to
to spread to to the territory of Russia
and second the consequences of using
those weapons will trigger a response
from other nuclear powers and I don't
think that's in the interest interest of
of Russia or of Putin no matter how how
crazy and how power math he is
um you know as I said it's a real
pleasure to have you on the program and
we can only imagine frankly you know
what the last sort of nine months or so
has been like for people in Ukraine so I
just wondered if you might feel
comfortable sharing a bit of that with
us
um you're obviously a politician you're
out there you're making the arguments
for more helpful Ukraine you're also
someone who's been pictured with an
AK-47 saying that you'd be prepared to
fight for your country and you're also a
mother
um I think I'm right in saying that your
youngest was still a baby when the war
broke out
how has it been for you and for your
family
a roller coaster that's that's to sum it
up in one word and I think it's been
like that for All Families in Ukraine
one day we we smile and we can't help
smiling because of the advances of the
Ukrainian military at the front lines
the next day we have some news coming in
from the Kremlin which is very much
offsetting and we realize that it's
probably part of some kind of
psychological attack on the on the next
day I will be in tears several times a
day because of the of the news coming in
of the convoys of the civilian convoys
that have been shot at and seeing the
pictures of mothers like me with
children who were trying to get to
safety who were just shot point blank in
their faces or in their backs that's uh
you know
those are things that your brain just
can't comp how do you say the word
psychological
compartmentalize basically put into
boxes and tuned into into compartments
it just gets to you the war gets to you
and I have to live in Awareness that I
am living this war and my family is
living this war with me no matter how
far I am able to actually put them uh
out from the country and into safety but
um you know every single Ukrainian will
be affected and disaffected already and
it's the pain and the tragedy and the
aftermath of the war which we will still
have to deal with even after the Russian
soldiers leave Ukrainian land